I don't know if Dale jr. has ever been
booed he joins us down Junior have you
been booed before absolutely I mean
everybody's been booed if they played in
guys sport at some point
well what about driving did you ever get
booed while you were like you got out of
a car and you didn't finish or you
finished
you know last or something people boo
you yeah really I'm sure I mean yeah
well yeah I'm sure Cowboys fans a lot me
a hammer yeah we're kind of arc rivals
at one point so I'm sure his fans
weren't very happy with me a lot of time
do you carry any of these feuds over
okay like does it get is it still
personal in any way with any of these
drivers to you well not really you know
hey I hate feeling that way I don't like
that in my because I can't shake it I'll
think about it all time I got a problem
with a driver
it just goes wherever I go and I hate
that feeling and I like to be I like to
be in good relationships with people I
like to have I like to have everything
positive so when I'm not on good terms
with a driver it eats at me it kind of
you know it's hard not to let it get
consumed and there's there's some like
there's drivers that'll say things about
you that you don't like and that sticks
with you for a really long time nothing
really you can do about that to get back
at them or or fix the situation but is
it still there with the driver do you
have a feud going on right now or you
don't like a driver you yeah I mean I
think the Artic said about me a couple
years when was last year the year before
that's tough
well sticker I think for a really long
time at that bothered me pretty bad
but I don't have a few keys like I don't
have I don't I don't have a guy that
spun me out that I never got back or
somebody that roughed me up on the
racetrack too many times that that still
digs in my side a little bit
well Harvick said I think I'm
paraphrasing that you stunted NASCAR's
growth like you like I think right is
that the quote yeah I think that's
pretty much what he said yeah that's not
a good quote I can understand what did
you ever say like what you hey would you
explain what what you're talking about
here no no I didn't want to because I
didn't think that he I think that he at
that point was intentionally trying to
dig at me
and I did I mean getting him to explain
it wouldn't have made me feel any better
because I know I know it was a personal
dig so hmm
and you're not a guy you didn't throw
punches right you wouldn't have taken
matters into your own hands you know I'm
not with Harvick I mean he's got a he's
got a wrestling background but you got
to think about your opponent with you in
general there is a point where anybody
gets to that point you know and where a
physical you know physical aggression is
this is it's not it's not what you want
to it's not what you want to do and it
always will be something you'll regret
but sometimes you know you get point you
get pushed to a certain point I think
that that's that cut that becomes an
option for anybody at a certain point
he's Dale jr. the former NASCAR driver
now part of NBC Sports joining NASCAR
America on NBCSN each Wednesday night at
5:00 Eastern what can we expect from
this show it's really just kind of it's
a it's kind of like just a couple guys
hanging out shooting the breeze on
what's going on in this war and what's
coming up the next particularly can
sometimes we
Joan topics that so there's a lot of
things going on in this board and
everybody's got an opinion on how to how
to do this better do that better and so
we touch on we touch on different topics
about within the sport about how to you
know there for example coming up this
weekend at Texas they have this tire
dragon thing that they use the rubber up
the racetrack everybody's got an opinion
on how to use that thing and what it
does and so we kind of dig into that a
little bit and have a little fun with it
and we get a driver in there but once
allowed to jump in chime in and try to
push them to be part of the conversation
which is fun because I was on the end of
that at one point you know the media
kind the media loves to get you the
media loves to get you to throw down a
quote or say something that's going to
be impactful and so it's fun for me to
be on the other side of that and try to
you know try to get a driver to get in
the middle of conversation try to get
them in trouble but it's not get them in
trouble no you don't want to get him in
trouble just get them in the middle to
get them to speak up then a lot of guys
just you know myself included depending
on the topic you just didn't want to get
in the middle of you didn't want to wait
in there because you're gonna you know
once you're in the conversation you get
asked about it the next week at the
racetrack and you might kick off some of
the drivers with the way you think so a
lot of times you you don't want to get
in there drivers just don't feel like
it's a you know it's worth the hassle to
get in the middle as conversations or
say something or so now to put out a
quote on something going on this sport
but it's fun being on this side of it
trying to make that happen we're talking
to Dale jr. by the way you can download
his podcast on dirty mow media I got an
idea for you for the NFL Draft how about
you announced the Redskins pick oh man
what do you think on what the pick is I
think you know I don't want to get booed
and what's going to be in Dallas booty
the way yes
what if would have Washington what's
Washington's picked
do we know where the Redskins pick or
McLovin do you have that cuz should
shooters the first-round guy he's not
gonna be a second well I don't know
would you rather go second round than
then first round I don't care I mean it
I'd be I think second would be easier
because I'd be sitting I'm nervous to go
there and do the first round but any fan
that gets to do that they're gonna get
up here and do it and I definitely take
opportunities ever got that channel you
know what it's the 13th overall pick
junior yeah okay yeah is what it is
I think they'll get a great player would
you do it if they asked you to and here
with the 13th pick for the Washington
Redskins
say hello to Dale Earnhardt jr. what if
you didn't like would you change would
you change the pick if you didn't like
it like just got up there and decided
you know what I don't like this guy
you know we need we need a wide receiver
we're gonna take Calvin Ridley of
Alabama's I would love it if you got it
of course you got to do that yeah I'm
gonna get my people on this Paulie get
on that right now we're on it okay
yeah we gotta get jr. hasn't had enough
fun and success in his life he needs
something to pick him up you know when's
the baby what's the baby due the baby is
due the second of May so we're literally
in the last month here a countdown
minute but that's one week after the
draft and I'm sure Amy would say yeah
I'll be fine you can go to Dallas in may
help oh maybe next year all right you're
on Lockyer go to the draft lockdown okay
all right yeah I mean I'm nervous I'm
nervous to do or go anywhere cuz this
could happen any moment so okay you're
you don't drive a minute are you gonna
drive a minivan no suburban suburban
okay can you put a baby seat in the in
the suburban do you know how to do this
I do not know how to do it just yet but
I have the baby seat do you have a safe
room ready start practicing do you have
a pit crew to help you with the baby no
okay crew okay I mean you're driving 200
miles an hour last year and now you're
gonna try to put a baby seat in the
suburban what happened to you June I
became became I'm becoming the father
I'm its I mean this weekend Amy's got a
couple showers so we're getting ready to
get in the house ready for that the
weather they're not supposed to be real
good here so we're gonna have doing
inside so we're getting mouse all ready
for that we've been getting the nursery
ready we've been unpacking and putting
things together put her stroller
together got to see that the Box got
getting it ready to go and suburban
things are happening and it's getting
exciting and you're having a girl I went
over to the hospital we had a little
girl I went over the hospital a day and
took the tour so I know where to go
where to where to where to bring onward
lobby is how to get up in there they
give me this some kind of card sign
right there now yeah and this is another
excuse you get to drive fast one more
time
like if her water breaks you got to get
there yeah I know I'm excited we got we
drive there and the drive home are going
to be two completely different graphs
yes that's true yeah now do you know
what you're doing like it I I'm gonna
tell you this you're you're are you
gonna do centerfield camera are you
gonna go behind home plate for the
delivery I you know I'm just gonna I'm
good I just can't wait because she gets
here I can't wait to meet her I'm gonna
be over there on that little table when
she's over there and I during the tour
the other day we went and they took us
into one of the rooms and to show us
where the delivery room is and they got
that little table there and damn I
thought Chuck dumbasses
baby ain't even here and I'm looking at
this little table and I'm getting choked
up like she's here so it
it's gonna be incredible what's your
needle experience and with telling your
name we got her name we got a name
figured out we're gonna not tell anybody
I get real big trophy oh yeah I don't
want that I don't want that to happen
you know I thought I could I thought
yeah I thought I could get it out of you
in this emotional moment will she will
she will she win the NASCAR title in 25
years no I don't I hope she I hope she
does something completely different with
her life and that's gonna be that's
gonna be something I'm interested in
learning is whether she would even care
about what I did
well even raced her you know will she
like she's gonna look at stuff online or
videos and go how that was you I don't
that you know so she it might not even
be anything he cares about and with
today's you know technology and
everything that these kids have their
fingertips there's so many other ways or
life to go things he'll be interested in
I don't know it will have to worry too
much about building racecars and
investing in because racing a cheap man
like 10 years old 15 years old it's
expensive so I'm hoping that she goes
another group well good luck and and
you'll forget everything that you've
been told so just know that you're not
alone with that when you get in there
you're gonna probably get yelled at and
you're probably gonna you know screw up
a little bit
but when it's all said and done as long
as you got her in your arms and
everybody's healthy then you know what
you move on you'll so I like it don't be
nervous
hey great to talk to you again Thank You
Junior thanks thanks good talk to you
guys and see y'all later that's Dale jr.
former NASCAR driver for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
you